una vez cuando éramos pequeños todos
aprendimos que Asia es el continente más
grande y más poblado del mundo y que
dentro de Asia también estaba el país
más habitado del planeta china sin
embargo esto ya no es así 24 de abril de
2023 India se convierte en el país más
poblado efectivamente lo que durante
tanto tiempo se pronosticó al fin ha
ocurrido la India ha superado a China en
población según las estimaciones en
julio de 2023 la India ya supera por
unos escasos 3 millones de personas a
China sin embargo esta diferencia se va
a ir incrementando con el paso del
tiempo para que os hagáis una idea los
expertos estiman que la población de
China caerá de forma constante hasta los
800 millones para finales de siglo
Mientras tanto la India tocará los 1.700
millones en el año 2060 y cerrará el
siglo con unos 1.500 millones de
habitantes es decir que para finales del
siglo XXI la población de la India
prácticamente duplicará a la china y que
supone esto pues para china todo un reto
por ejemplo para el 2050 habrá 700
millones de trabajadores en China es
decir 200 millones menos que en 2011 y
estos 700 millones además tendrán que
hacer frente a los costes que supondrá
tener 500 millones de chinos mayores de
60 años 300 millones más que en la
actualidad y no solo eso china también
se arriesga a perder una de sus mayores
fortalezas la mano de obra barata sin
embargo hoy no os vamos a hablar de
china hoy venimos a hablaros del nuevo
campeón demográfico en que se ha
convertido la India
[Música]
un país que sigue siendo muy pobre y que
todavía no ha conseguido igualar a China
en cuanto a productividad económica o
nivel de vida y la pregunta es por qué
no lo han hecho pues podríamos destacar
muchos elementos una excesiva burocracia
un agresivo proteccionismo el sistema de
castas del que recientemente os hemos
hablado y también su incapacidad Crónica
para desarrollar un factor crucial para
el desarrollo económico tener una fuerte
infraestructura que es precisamente a lo
que vamos a dedicar Este vídeo pero
queridos amigos amigas cómo ha llegado
la India hasta aquí cómo está afrontando
narendra móvil el resto de la falta
Crónica de infraestructuras puede
convertirse la India en el nuevo
epicentro mundial de las manufacturas
qué industria puede poner en jaque los
planes geopolíticos de Jean Pink hoy
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
Castilla política India
empecemos con una pregunta que os puede
pillar algo desprevenidos qué sabes de
la historia de la India seguramente
muchos habréis contarme algún dato sobre
el Mahatma Gandhi y su Apuesta por la no
violencia y seguro que la mayoría
también sabéis que fue una antigua
Colonia británica pero algo más lo más
probable es que no normalmente de la
India solo nos resaltan su enorme
población sin embargo este gigante es
mucho más que eso y su historia es
crucial para entender la actual India
[Aplausos]
independizada en 1947 del imperio
británico bajo el liderazgo de Gandhi la
India es un estado Federal relativamente
joven desde su comienzo tuvo que
afrontar un escenario económico muy poco
productivo basado en la agricultura de
subsistencia Hasta el 70% de la
población vivía de ella sin embargo tras
el asesinato de Randy en 1948 llegó el
poder su compañero y figura principal de
la independencia llamo y entonces la
India comenzó su camino hacia el
desarrollo económico el nuevo Primer
Ministro de la India comenzó a dirigir
la economía desde el propio estado y en
1951 creó el primer plan quinquenal del
país este plan nacionalizó la minería el
sector energético y la industria pesada
todos ellos fueron clasificados como
sectores estratégicos también se
implantó un estricto sistema de
licencias que engrosó desmesuradamente
la burocracia lo cual hizo que durante
su mandato el cual se extendió hasta
1964 la economía apenas logrará crecer
un 2,5%, un nivel insuficiente para
acabar con el desempleo crónico o la
pobreza o la desnutrición
[Música]
más tarde con la muerte de neru en 1964
y de su sucesor La al bajador sastre en
1966 llegó otra de las figuras más
importantes de la historia del país
Indira Gandhi y no no es la hija del
Mahatma sino del propio neru
Indira Gandhi gobernó desde 1966 hasta
1984 de manera casi ininterrumpida a
excepción de los 3 años que transcurren
entre 1977 y 1980 durante el resto del
tiempo fue dueña y señora del país y qué
es lo que hizo durante sus dos mandatos
Pues básicamente continuar con los
planes económicos de sus padres
nacionalizó el sistema bancario las
minas de Carbón y las compañías
petroleras entre otras sin embargo pese
a todo seguramente el principal hito de
la primera ministra India fue la
erradicación casi por completo del
hambre a través de la conocida
Revolución verde y En qué consistió esta
Revolución Pues esencialmente en la
introducción de cultivos con
rendimientos mucho más altos como el
arroz enano el uso generalizado de
fertilizantes y pesticidas y la mejora
de los sistemas de regadío no obstante
en octubre de 1984 cuatro meses
después de producirse un enfrentamiento
entre el estado y los separatistas de la
religión sic fue asesinada por algunos
de sus guardaespaldas que profesaban esa
misma religión pero amigos si creíais
que eso de las dinastías políticas era
solo cosa de los Kennedy a craso error
sabéis quién tomó las riendas del país
tras el asesinato de Indira Gandhi
Exacto su hijo rail Gandhi y qué hizo
exactamente Rey allí pues realmente no
cambió demasiadas cosas continuó con el
legado de su madre y su abuelo
pese a todo al final Durante los años 80
la India logró crecer por encima del 3%.
incluso tuvo Algunos años razonablemente
buenos la evolución dado el nivel de
pobreza del país no era para tirar
cohetes pero Aparentemente tampoco un
desastre sin embargo El problema es que
este crecimiento tenía gato encerrado
durante años la India creció a base de
deuda y como ya pasó en América Latina a
principios de los 80 la India sufrió una
crisis financiera en 1990 Fue entonces
cuando en 1991 siendo Primer Ministro
narasim hará la India comenzó a abrirse
al mundo se redujo drásticamente la
burocracia eliminando buena parte del
sistema de licencias de neru
disminuyeron los aranceles y las
reservas monetarias acabaron creciendo
desde los 3.000 millones de dólares en
1991 hasta los 25 mil millones en 1995
Sin embargo a la India le seguía
faltando algo que consolidara y
expandiera su crecimiento económico algo
que su vecina china ya estaba
desarrollando infraestructura Pues bien
así comenzó el impulso de la
infraestructura en este subcontinente de
asia prestad mucha atención
[Música]
make India
un país necesita infraestructura sin
carreteras sin centrales eléctricas o
sin tecnología difícilmente un país
puede prosperar en el siglo XXI por eso
mismo en África los países trabajan
tanto con china porque el gigante
asiático les facilita préstamos y ayudas
para construir todas esas
infraestructuras básicas que resultan
indispensables para alcanzar el
desarrollo Pues bien de todo esto se dio
cuenta en la India el Primer Ministro a
tal viajar y valli en 1998 y por eso
impulsó el famoso proyecto llamado
cuadrilátero de oro un proyecto que
conecta por carretera 4 de las
principales ciudades del país Nueva
Delhi en el norte Calcuta en el este
chenai en el sur y bombay en el oeste
todo con miras a mejorar los
intercambios económicos dentro del país
pero desde luego este impulso no se
quedó ahí su sucesor Man moján sing que
llegó al poder en 2004 impulsó la
construcción de los corredores dedicados
al transporte de mercancías por tren de
hecho hizo de estos el eje principal del
plan quinquenal de 2007-2012 y hoy ya
están en funcionamiento dos de estos
corredores el occidental de 1500
kilómetros de largo y el Oriental que es
el más largo con 1900 kilómetros de
longitud va desde Luciana la ciudad más
poblada de punjab hasta tancuni que es
parte del área metropolitana de Calcuta
no obstante pese a todo lo cierto es que
los avances seguían siendo demasiado
lentos
Claro en un país tan poblado y con
ciudades extraordinariamente grandes os
podéis imaginar el enorme problema que
eso supone carreteras colapsadas trenes
atestados de gente circulando a
velocidades extremadamente lentas cortes
de Electricidad problemas con los plazos
de entrega de las mercancías etcétera
etcétera Pues bien fue entonces de
pronto en 2014 cuando irrumpió en la
política nacional India una particular
figura de la que ya os hemos hablado en
este canal narendramody ya os hemos
contado en otros vídeos cómo está
manejando mod y el país las denuncias
por la violación de Derechos Humanos son
constantes y Muchas de sus promesas
económicas quedaron prácticamente en la
nada sin embargo sigue siendo un
político muy popular en el país y
precisamente uno de sus grandes empeños
ha sido y está siendo mejorar las
infraestructuras y no como sus
predecesores sino a lo y todo bajo una
nueva iniciativa la iniciativa make
India
[Música]
impulsado en 2014 por el propio móvil la
iniciativa making India Busca hacer de
la India el manufacturero más importante
de todo el mundo incluso por encima de
China el objetivo es que el peso del
sector de las manufacturas pase del 17%
actual a más del 25 por el camino
esperan crear de paso 100 millones de
puestos de trabajo en este sector Para
ello el gobierno de la India se ha
centrado en construir una mejor
infraestructura que sea capaz de atraer
más inversiones e incentivar la
innovación de 25 sectores concretos
entre los que destacan la energía los
productos químicos los sistemas
electrónicos o el sector automovilístico
por el momento la iniciativa aparece
estar dando sus frutos ya que desde el
año fiscal 2012-2013 hasta el 2020 2021
el año principal de la pandemia de la
covid la inversión extranjera directa
pasó de unos 34.000 millones de dólares
a tocar los 82.000
Durante este tiempo modi ha impulsado la
construcción de más de 10.000 kilómetros
nuevos de autovías cada año se han
construido más de 45 nuevos aeropuertos
civiles y hay decenas más en
construcción se han desarrollado nuevos
puertos nuevos sistemas de transporte
Metropolitano y también miles y miles de
kilómetros de nuevos ferrocarriles a lo
largo y ancho de todo el país con todo
ello se persigue además un objetivo
crucial lograr reducir los costes
logísticos del país que se sitúan en un
14% del pib A menos del 8% del pib para
el año 2030 una infraestructura
eficiente resulta absolutamente clave
para la competitividad del sector
Industrial ya lo veis queridos amigos
amigas de visualpolitik Mode le ha
puesto las pilas a la India para
intentar superar a China no solo en
población sino también en manufacturas
Ese es su gran objetivo Así que para el
Primer Ministro indio esto no ha hecho
más que empezar
[Música]
de hecho el presupuesto de 2023 dedicado
a la construcción de infraestructuras ha
crecido un 33% con respecto al año
anterior hasta alcanzar el 3,3% del pib
es decir 122 mil millones de dólares
además también han decidido extender los
préstamos sin intereses a 50 años para
todos aquellos gobiernos estatales que
quieran invertir en infraestructura y no
solo eso la inversión en Inteligencia
artificial sobre todo para su
incorporación en la educación también es
uno de sus ejes fundamentales y cómo no
se va a seguir invirtiendo en los
corredores de mercancías tanto en los
dos que están ya casi acabados y que
están funcionando ahora casi al 100%
como en otros tres proyectos que ya se
han aprobado sin embargo y a pesar de la
construcción de infraestructura Hay un
problema que podría alejar la inversión
hacia la India oscuras Noches de verano
indias se enfrenta a un alto riesgo de
cortes de electricidad tras años de
abandono del Carbón y la energía
hidráulica efectivamente hablamos del
suministro eléctrico
la India lleva al menos tres años con
cortes de Electricidad sobre todo
nocturnos debido a la escasez de Carbón
y su pobre y anticuada infraestructura y
como ya os podéis imaginar esto supone
un problema fundamental para toda la
industria para solucionar este problema
la India tiene proyectada la
construcción de 26 plantas eléctricas de
carbón en los próximos 10 años Sí sí
carbón sea como sea lo más seguro es que
la India aún tarde décadas en alcanzar a
China como principal productor de
manufacturas del mundo si es que lo
consigue algún día por supuesto esto no
significa que la India no vaya a
convertirse en un actor económico tan
crucial como lo es hoy en día china
incluso hay una industria que de llegar
a desarrollarse en la India podría
llegar a desbaratar muchos de los planes
geopolíticos de Pekín atentos
[Música]
la geopolítica del semiconductor
hackers una pregunta Qué componente
electrónico necesitan un móvil un coche
o incluso un misil teledirigido para
poder funcionar seguramente muchos no lo
sabréis pero es algo de lo que ya os
hemos hablado tanto en nuestro canal
hermano visual economic como en si lo
hubiera sabido si aún no los conocéis os
dejamos todos los enlaces en la
descripción os estamos hablando por
supuesto de los semiconductores y sabéis
Qué país tiene todo el potencial de
convertirse en un punto principal de la
producción de semiconductores
efectivamente la India veréis modi no
pretende crear e impulsar empresas desde
cero en la India sino atraer a grandes
firmas al país y tampoco es una locura
pensarlo bien tienen cuatro ventajas un
gran mercado interno un amplio
conocimiento del inglés una mano de obra
relativamente muy barata y una de las
mayores canteras del licenciados en
ciencias tecnología ingeniería y
matemáticas por todo esto no es de
extrañar que ya nos este encontrando con
noticias como estas y se me hace digital
invertirá 3000 millones en una unidad de
fabricación de chips en carnataca os
connieve datan construirán en la India
una fábrica de chips por valor de 19.000
millones de dólares y precisamente esto
queridos amigos de visualpolitik es uno
de los mayores temores de China Pero la
pregunta es por qué Pues veréis como ya
sabéis India y China no son precisamente
los mejores amigos del mundo mantienen
reivindicaciones territoriales Y ambos
países aspiran a convertirse en la
principal potencia regional en Asia
por ejemplo china ha estado expandiendo
su poder por el mar de la China
meridional y aún más preocupante para la
India por otros países de Asia como
Pakistán o sri lanka pero por su parte
India también ha hecho lo mismo jugando
con su posición geoestratégica en las
islas del mar de andamán y fortaleciendo
vínculos con países como omán las Islas
o Indonesia puntos clave que llegado el
caso podrían cortar el suministro del
crudo que llega a por mar desde el golfo
Pérsico hasta china Hablamos de una
incipiente lucha que ha llevado
inevitablemente a que la India se
acerque cada vez más a Estados Unidos
hace concesiones y modi sale de su zona
de Confort durante una elaborada visita
de estado a la casa blanca pero ojo este
acercamiento No solo le interesa el
propio móvil sino también a la
administración biden Estados Unidos
necesita India como socio estratégico
para equilibrarse frente a China tanto
en el sur de Asia como en el mundo
Pacífico India necesita Estados Unidos a
medida que desarrolla un futuro más
próspero y ecológico Hablamos de una
alianza que en Washington consideran
absolutamente clave para contener a
China no solo por el enorme peso
económico y político que la India
adquirirá Durante los próximos años y
décadas o porque este país puede ser una
alternativa natural a la dependencia que
el mundo occidental ha desarrollado
hacia las fábricas chinas sino también
por una razón muy simple la
vulnerabilidad geopolítica de Taiwán y
os preguntaréis pero tiene que ver
Taiwán aquí pues mucho recordad que
Taiwán es el mayor productor de
semiconductores del mundo
[Música]
si la producción taiwanesa separara
repentinamente por una posible invasión
china el mundo entraría en pánico y
quizás también se detendría una parte
importante de la economía los
semiconductores son cruciales para la
industria de todo el mundo precisamente
por eso Estados Unidos está invirtiendo
de manera decidida en esta industria por
ejemplo en agosto del año pasado se
aprobaron leyes que incluían una
inversión de más de 50.000 millones de
dólares para fortalecer su propia
producción de semiconductores también
están presionando para que empresas
taiwanesas como tsmc trasladen allí
parte de sus operaciones de ese mes
invertirá 40.000 millones de dólares en
Arizona con su segunda planta de Chip
semiconductores hoy Estados Unidos
produce en torno al 12% de todos los
semiconductores del mundo muy por debajo
de Taiwán una isla que además produce la
inmensa la mayor parte de los
semiconductores más avanzados
Pues bien si tal y como se pretende se
consigue hacer crecer la producción de
chips en países como Estados Unidos
Japón o la propia India además de Corea
del Sur china perdería una importante
baja estratégica su capacidad potencial
para amenazar a las economías
occidentales con la invasión de Taiwán
se reduciría muchísimo
y no solo eso si la India logra
posicionarse en este campo por
probablemente eso también animaría a
muchas empresas tecnológicas a trasladar
aquí su actual producción en China y
como veis en toda esta historia las
infraestructuras resultan absolutamente
claves la India necesita conectarse al
mundo y lograr que su economía pueda
funcionar de forma ágil y barata
necesita que Los profesionales y las
mercancías puedan moverse de forma
rápida y económica y necesita también
garantizar un suministro eléctrico
abundante y competitivo pero amigos
llegados Hasta aquí las preguntas una
hora para todos vosotros creéis que la
India conseguirá superar también
económicamente a China logrará
convertirse en uno de los principales
productores de semiconductores y reducir
el riesgo que supone china puedes
dejarnos vuestras respuestas abajo en
los comentarios como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a este canal y dale a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle al botón de
like y nos vemos en el próximo un saludo
y hasta pronto
[Música]